"Transformers: Rise of the Beasts" introduces
a new set of robots in disguise, but it takes
place in the 1990s, well before the
entries in the series directed by
Michael Bay. So why didn't the Autobots
ever mention their pals the Maximals?
Spoilers for "Rise of the Beasts" ahead!
The continuity of the live-action "Transformers"
films has always been pretty sketchy,
even within the five directed by Michael Bay.
2018's "Bumblebee," which took place in 1987,
ostensibly functions as a soft reboot of
the franchise, but it's also a prequel,
showing what Bumblebee was up to before he met
Sam Witwicky in the first "Transformers" movie.
"You talk through the radio?"
"Thank you, you're beautiful.
You're wonderful, you're wonderful."
"Rise of the Beasts" supposedly takes
place within this same timeline,
with the previous cinematic installment
being directly referenced when Optimus
Prime mentions how Bumblebee had
already made friends with humans.
Connecting the two most recent "Transformers"
movies with Michael Bay's entries in the franchise
can prove troublesome, especially now that the
Maximals have been introduced. They've been on
Earth for a long time, and after the climactic
battle, it's assumed they're still around,
probably continuing to be based in Peru. So
if "Rise of the Beasts" leads into Bay films,
it raises the question of why the
Maximals didn't help out during all
of those potential world-ending events.
The Maximals are even the ones who have
to teach Optimus Prime to work alongside the
humans, so they likely have just as much of
an interest in protecting humanity, if not
more. Why did they remain in hiding then?
After the good guys succeed in destroying
the Transwarp Key and preventing Unicron
from coming to Earth, everyone seemingly
goes their separate ways. The Autobots
are more accepting of humanity, while
the human characters are changed for
the better. It's unclear what exactly
the Maximals get up to, but presumably,
they go back to living in the Peruvian jungle
with the indigenous tribe they befriended.
It's understandable that they don't necessarily
want to be bothered with every little thing,
but the Michael Bay "Transformers"
movies have some significant threats
that put the entire world in jeopardy.
It's unclear why the Autobots wouldn't
call on them again to help them
to fight off the Decepticons.
"Roll out!"
There may be another factor at play here, though:
No one can seem to decide if "Bumblebee" and
"Rise of the Beasts" are prequels to the Bay
films straight-up reboots. Some things are
seemingly canon. Megatron, for example, wasn't
in "Bumblebee" or "Rise of the Beasts" because
the other entries establish he was frozen
during those decades. "Bumblebee" director
Travis Knight even told The Hollywood Reporter he
couldn't use Megatron in his film for that reason.
On the other hand, there's a lot that's seemingly
being retconned in the new "Transformers"
movies. For one, 2017's "The Last Knight"
established how Unicron was actually Earth,
with its horns protruding out of the planet's
surface. "Rise of the Beasts," however,
shows Unicron as a completely separate entity.
The new movie also has a final scene where
Noah is recruited by G.I. Joe, potentially
setting up a crossover event between the two
Hasbro franchises. This would only open up more
questions as to how the movies fit in with Bay's.
It's possible the explanation for why the
Maximals aren't in any other "Transformers"
movie is that these new ones take place
in a different timeline. If Paramount does
want to keep everything under one roof, the
Maximals' exclusion could be explained in a
future installment. Perhaps they sacrifice
their lives valiantly to protect Earth,
or maybe they find a way off the planet. At
the end of the day, these are movies about
robot aliens that turn into cars, so maybe
it's best not to think too hard about it.